Do you guys want these guns?
I know where a third gun is
Do you guys want these guns? ;)
..these guns?
My guns are bigger than your guns
Hey, Stacy, you impressed. Oh
That's our sister, Isn't it. Ah no, no. Its our cousin get it right? I'm sorry
[Bob] DAaw, [Wade] I drank a lot of
uh... bees
Oh, it just says beer..
[Bob] I-I know I'm your cousin on account of all the sex we had had
Yeah
With me right, not him. I can't remember
THESE!!
Do you mean it's Kinda hard to tell maybe can you bend over forward I remember your ass pretty well.
I will oh my crotch is right there is that good for you? Oh?
Yeah, this is this is what I like. Are you... Oh my God wait mark please jump again (Amazing Bob laugh)
When you're not holding anything and you jump, look at Mark's jump sequence Wade. WOAH
What am I doing? I've no idea! No, Wade, Wade jump for me, you do it you do it
That's some pretty incredible ab work. You got their Wade, What does mine look like? Does mine look insanely dirty?
No, you just kind of prancing a bit
All right, let's get out there and find bigfoot. Do we want one person to be our tracker?
Do we want to solve that tracking bullet? We should have one tracker cuz there's some confusion sometimes a switching between the two I
I clearly don't have a gun so I probably shouldn't be the track. I'll do the track. i'll track.
I'm dedicated tracker this time. I won't screw it up. Don't forget your flare guns and your rope, all right. I got rope don't worry about it
Oh I know we used it on you last night sister cousin, sister cousin
It's called a 'Sousin' dude! I've forgotten that. That's it. That's the term we use.. A Sousin.
It's Sousin Bobby-boy.
Wade, why do you look so funny when you're walking you walk it a little bit of a crouch like what the fuck are you doing?
Yeah, you do to!
How do I look?
Laughter :)
All right lets all do our draggley arm run and go to the island.
Someone should track him and I'm pretty sure our missing persons are along the paths somewhere...
Ahhh. The paths you say.. When Bob and I were playing, What is a path? (Odd noise) What the fuck was that?
Wait, what d'you hear? I heard someone go... B-Ohhhhhh
Oh, I didn't hear that, if you hear flies, that's the sound of the bodies being near. Well, then what the f-f-f...
What the fuck did I just hear? I don't know I didn't hear that either!
Hey being a little out of my mind is kind of exciting isn't it Stacy? ;)
I mean, well don't forget these
I wasn't even looking I didn't even get to enjoy the show oh
God, that's good. Hey, that makes me wanna shoot you right in there Stacy! Wait, no no no. That would actually kill me, Stacy. What about this?
i hear voices in my head
Pretty good, huh, yeah like that
That's good, all right, so if I'm gonna pick the winner who gets to bone me tonight Mm-hmm
I'm gonna need to see some sensitivity out of you guys, [okay]? All right. I enjoyed corn dogs and walks on the beach
Mmm, okay, my go. I think corn dogs are gross and I like walks on hard pavement
Practical I like that. hey you want to touch meats? oh, hell. Yeah, you know I do
How about this hmmm wow?
Slappy just slap it a little oh God yeah, yeah
Are you gonna sell this to hotmeat.com? hell Yeah, hope no bigfoots come by and see this mmm
Yeah, what are we doing about bigfoot or something? yeah we do sum about bigfoot in these woods?
What it is I heard a rustling
Oh I'm
I'm not hearing anything
Oh, I thought I heard a rustling... then again. I hear voices in my head apparently!
Sousin Wade? Why are we letting you lead us you don't seem to Understand...
I'm following the paths to try and find the missing person
What path? There's no road here?
Well if you press the Q
Oh ok, I got you yeah, What do you mean press the Q..? Its a sex thing...
Sousin Wade..  Don't, don't press my cue or I guess you're a Bousin... A Brousin. Oh, There he is!
Should I track him brother brousin wade? Yes? You see ya, haha. He's long gone, no
He's way down the road there oop can't see anything with that. Oh yeah there he goes...
He goes since our mission was just sort of a find bigfoot is that like?
mission accomplished..? Orrrr
You mean, stop there just go home okay? I mean, I feel pretty good about that hmm. Oh
her rearicles appear to be
Extending Outward. What are you talking about? Don't look at her rearicles! Her legs a little...
Hey, you, okay? ARE YOU ALRIGHT? you okay?
You think she's dead? Her arm is also, I mean whats wrong with her arm?
Is she an alien they all long that arm is? Ooh, that's not right? Yeah, it's not normal
She's not human, huh? Oh, so we shouldn't feel bad
No! Fuck this Alien. We should be glad this Alien scum is dead.
Big foot is just protecting these woods from fucking alien invaders.
That's what's happening here, brousins.
Okay, I scent.. I'm picking up a trail
I think he's pooping he must live near here, okay, all right, man doesn't smell good
Smells like hes been eating alien
Hmm. How would you possibly know an alien smells like you fucking liar, I'm a professional? He's an alien! wait a minute. Oh...
I was wondering, wait. i didnt have a twin brother two days ago..
I was just thinking that! Yeah, how do you just randomly get a twin brother? Yeah, that's a little weird.. Yes you do!
Ive always been there. Remember?
I told you when  I held that thing infront of your face? I don't think that true at all! This is a fucking alien clone we've got walking around here.
Well, I'm not an alien
Wait, so do I get to choose which one of you dies? Yeah, I suppose that seems fair that's exciting
Well, we'll just keep looking for bigfoot and I'll choose at some point. [I'll] let you know okay. All right. Thank you suggest
It's not sure fire way. I can guarantee. I'll proves. I'm not an alien, okay
I'd like to see this all right all right. I promise. I'm not an alien.
(Bob shoots) Oh. God. Sorry
I thought you were going to say that you were an alien.. We just that you want really whoa all
Right follow follow me moving on frozen wade. I'm gonna get back this one's betrayal. I was following
This was a trail, but what z trail okay the trail we need to follow uh-huh this way, okay?
Ah you guys have your meat ready, right?
Why would we need that he if he leads us to his alien ship, shoot him before he takes us on board, okay?
All right, but what if I'm the alien?
Bob: I'll shoot you don't worry about it. Mark: Okay. Thanks
Thank you, I
Bob: Think either way, I probably both you, but you know we'll get there when we get there. Best to be safe
I don't even know if I'm not an alien you know yeah, I can't after watching my gun turned bloody
I don't know
Yeah, you know what mark Listen mark even if you do turn out to be an alien your candor and honesty about your feelings-
(God Objects With Lightning)
Mark: WTF?
What alien fucker did that which one of you fucking alien bitches did that I?
Uhhhh
Im not 100 percent sure about that. man. I we did not explore the lightning area
That's a cool fire. Tree. Wade: Oh, thers a tower here here. bob: Oh shit, son
Wade: Anybody need Anything? knew you think you're not just leading us to a jump-scare again because I have a funny feeling I remember something similar to this
happening before
Yeah, I don't have to go off on the tower this time. I didn't I did it last time on the rail
Ooh, this time dude. We do good
Hey, fucking I
Don't know what happened. I don't know what happen. I don't know what having it out. Early again
I ran over there, hotshot get it to replace all your I should I should probably get it. Yes, it's a blow on em
Oh, yeah, all your jokes bullets
Is your comedy shot?
Uh don't worry. It's just joke bullet
Jd. Felt wounded just relax. Uh it's a joke. Oh, Lola wound a joke whole come on. Yeah, oh
Really giving it to you write your joke
Oldest humor landing, and you're going all over lands right in my you looking for a little joke up
Yeah, man yourself just a quick one may be over behind one of those trees when you'll privacy here here
I'll help you I got oh
well
How did I not get him? He's tracked eat fresh. Hey Joey not?
Something is tracked. There's a tracking dart moving away on my map. Oh, I don't see it. You gotta follow your deal
No way, we can see it. Yeah, I can't see he's going back to his cave
always going to the me
following you
Susan I a I got hit and I used to help back I did, but I continued you got hit too
Yes, I was down to like twenty-five percent [health] what does not eat? Oh?
Did I shoot you accidentally you look guys? I don't mean it is jumbled come on
It's just a joke full of man just calm down. It's a joke bullet. Yeah, come on man
Let's uh let's let's do this presence. We're we're with you all
right here
Yeah, I tagged him again. I still don't see the tracking I can't see all I seem tracking down
He's by the dead bodies, but dead by seen dragging it
Oh crackers once until it wears off just so you know yeah. Yeah, I know it's just I go see it before
ok
Past a dead body on the path now Wolfie was about now. All right. Let's do this. He's coming right at me
I'm on the Middle island facing him and he's coming right at me. All right. I see him
I'm gonna get some shots on him, and then I'm gonna shoot my flare fuck you
All right, I've scared him back away from the island. He's going the same way it was before ok all right?
I'm still making my way downtown
I'm saying sal you
Whether cell north Northwest out of the floor. Where's going I'm going to reload [the] trackers because I imagine it's probably running out
Oh, hell. Yeah, I was coming up. He's coming back at me. I'm in the swamp right now
He's coming back at the edge of the swamp right at me
looking
Crappy laid out here. I to achieve I feel
I gotta go up. He's going to [the] south of me
All right, oh coming towards me. Come towards me. I'm gonna hit him with another tracker
Job out he's got him I think
I'm sorry, we're trekking we are dominating this bigfoot, bro. I'm gonna try to get a few more pop shots off
Yeah, oh nailed a min is noggin. I don't have a whole lot of ammo. Let's go fortunately I've still got
31 shots left, So I
Got plenty any of so many bullets after all those joke ones
Turns out that just jokes man. I don't know just joking all right. I'm on the path now behind him to the West
Okay, it looks like you stopped going that way, so I'm on about the path right by the bridge, so I'm gonna
I'm gonna Lay a trap on we had just we have this motherfucker pinched in so hard right now. Oh, I see him
Oh, it's right by me you terrify me. He's right by me
Nope, well, oh he ran past me. He's fucking running away. Oh
Here and pass started a pinch didn't work yeah. I mean Jesus. I didn't get my flare off
I tried to flare them back towards you but I think it's cuz they are day now
He doesn't really come at you at the day. Yeah. He was aggressive right now
Well, we got it out of like almost half yeah, wow yeah, that was a really good first hunt well
I'm [back] in at campers. I'm back at the camper. Oh hey. What's up we were equidistant away from each other. We're all alive
Yeah
And I had it out all
Right I'm gonna show you guys a little blue you're mine. Oh, I thought it could be different
Blow your load, okay? Well not what I was painting weed uh-huh hey ah
nee good look around in here ah
Most guys then Bobby Miller medicine. Oh yeah, I kind of do I'm
series um there's a guy with
Nursing Thor's hammer
Hey guys, nope Munoz Molten bernard bernard on here. Oh salsa
Jared's oh hey, what's up a hammer that I not the devil with feet year. That's not a
Bigfoot that's a big year. It's been our units big. It's his hands
He's big hands different and his right hand is a bit more grabby than his active that's right is rusted
That's bigfoot's frozen his right-handed pulling the grocery. [so] he just picked up at the ICa. He's just walking home just kidding
He's got that crazy head on doesn't mean. He's a bad guy
So wyd less for come in here makes to cave drawings and eat some deer that is really the gravy
Bigfoot killed core
Mm-Hmm, then what chance do we stand maybe bigfoot is
Mmm. I'm not I'm not as all of that. I don't like it was really just a stab in the dark there
Yeah, what I mean, I thought tried to go with you, but I just couldn't yeah
I'm not on board with it either in fact
I feel like I feel like you've [done] that all of us a disservice for even opening your mouth in the first place. Yeah
I mean we try and keep this forum open you [know] and it's like all ideas are welcome, but like that it's
Within within reason right like all right whatever smarty pants. Let's hear. What injuries
Why did a little ever cave? I'm not saying I have zero I'm just saying put in some effort. Yeah, it's late
It's like you're gonna throw an idea out there, and it's ours the whole room like that's just not productive
Well at least I'm throwing ideas that would I but no no no no that means fine throwing ideas
But we had that rule because we didn't know that there was such a bad alternative. We didn't think it was possible
Isn't the thing on top of the ground sleep late strap that I almost stepped in I?
Warned you like five times you can't complain when I warned you. I don't know
rightly placed
Even though you warned me. I still almost went to it. Yeah, no place Dang
Are you okay here? You can?
Be rubbing are you having like that?
Only say one word you have you having a voice a vocal problem. Yeah? Yeah, [yeahs]
My Pokemons stacked deck who's that Pokemon?
dick dick dick and Holman
I don't know man. You come up with a joke. I just came up with it my God
You can get the correction it
Should be actually you should be like yak this boner
boner
phone boat Boner Boner boner
please someone draw all of these non pokemon because
That just needs to exist
Someone who can draw please draw I can't draw I mean I could drive whoa, whoa, whoa?
Oh Fuckin Fuckin goddamn it alright. Got him with a tracker. I've only got one tracking bullet left that scared you so much
All right, where'd he go going towards a camper? I can't believe he hasn't hit it goddamn bullshit
But he beelines right [for] [ed]. We're just just walked through the woods just vamping on dick Pokemon
And he's just fucking comes out of nowhere like an asshole. Maybe he heard the Colin was like dick
Dick dick dick is a giant hand job poor
Really on so he watched up. It was just like I heard someone talking about the human centric nature of this world
Profession the awkward position of oppression that that puts us bigfoot people in
It's refreshing to hear of human was such an open I
Just wanted to talk about social issues. I know why bigfoot has a say voices fat man, uh
What [are] the other truck oh no? I just like this world where bigfoot is like always surprised in the middle of a sentence
Honey, I just don't feel feel that [feels] fulfilled at work, and I mean my boss is oh
Man to leave. They're really coming in early. I can't believe help. Oh
well
I've got two bullets. He's got a lot of hell. I've got a lot of bullets left
I'm at 31 shots 21 shots. I don't have a flare. He seems I be wanting to come after us
Maybe we should go to his cave
Because he seems to be tonight. He seems to be hitting us hard
Maybe it might be actually hold on let's go down here there might be another tower this little dead end path freighter
I'm not sure what's over here? Oh, I see what you mean. Yeah, you
Could follow you randomly this goes oh?
Oh, oh, God. That's loud fuck I
have a shitty [tense] it's
Just that does not happen. Oh
Shit, wait. Where's my flare fuck I mentioned with the flare on a plane from Iran Hang on oh
My aim be true
Miss him. No I got [him] I got him wait I see him. He's mark. I think it's coming to engage us yeah
Yeah, he's coming. Maybe yeah, he's coming. He's coming all right all right
Where are we letting them right here right here line it up right here is where we fight?
This oh my God be coming here. He goes until he cums. [how] you laid it on me
Oh my God now ow. Oh solo. You solo oh
Shit, yeah
I'm catching bigfoot you doing you actually big fun. You got it
What yeah?
We're not done yet. We got to put him in oh fuck. Oh
So I'm dragging him now. Are you guys leat where am I going back to the camper a little area is this way well?
We're actually really close to this kind of convenient. Yeah, you do all the work stan. I got it. Don't worry
Don't worry. Don't worry their presence. I got this you're all muscly and whatnot but did I didn't know it's all bloody
Yeah, we fucked him up man. What happen if I just hit closed door on you?
I did not hit that I didn't do that. I'm not a joker. Oh, yeah
mother oh
Wow
What's up, bro? Whoa?
Hey someone whoa. Oh look at that its goal light from like over there. Yeah, like that'll look at that that nasty thumbnail
That's so sick no no, no. I want a good thumbnail. You like [I] [hear] [me]. Oh
I light like this like that gear I get a raise of light disappear
God yeah, that's a good sum. Oh fuck okay. Well one of us is an alien do we were doing results. Oh, yeah?
Yeah, we didn't we didn't resolve this so um in all of our adventures here
Which of us seemed more human? I'll put my gun away. I'm pretty confident wait
I think I think we both know who's ylian, okay? Yeah, ha are you with me?
yeah, what I'm
know
Why you're reloading is very ominous? Oh, oh
I didn't even shoot back. I'm pretty sure you as a human. I must have been meeting all
You guys fell in exactly the same position look at that. He's not like we live you're spooning
So romantic except that we're dead